eu trabalho a garantir e o seu coração
essa bomba tanque músculo dentro do seu
peito
atá a quantidade de vezes que ele veio
programado para bater
considerando uma frequência cardíaca
média de 1 70 batimentos por minuto que
ele bata 100 mil vezes por dia 36
milhões de vezes por ano e se tivermos
sorte e fé e chegarmos até os 80 anos
que cheguemos a ponta de aproximadamente
quase 3 bilhões de batimentos em uma
vida parece bastante mas há
controvérsias pode acreditar ainda mais
quando nós estamos perto do fim
a frase o tempo é relativo nunca falar
tanto sentido quanto no fim do seu
próprio tempo
sim eu sou uma cardiologista e eu
estudei pra isso para garantir que o seu
coração bata direitinho até o fim
aliás continua estudando argumente já
que as doenças que atingem o seu coração
e fazem parar são a principal causa de
morte no brasil e no mundo
ninguém quer morrer quanto mais antes da
hora
sempre que eu penso em um coração dentro
de um paciente me intriga é uma questão
que vai além das questões meramente
médicas e fisiológicas
enfim pelo que bate coração pensando
nisso caímos numa questão intrigante a
miscelânea histórica e cultural que
atribui um outro significado particular
a este órgão físico é ao mesmo tempo um
na sagrada dos nossos mais nobres
sentimentos e de onde vem esse sentido
ambíguo que atribuímos a este órgão e ao
mesmo tempo o nosso coração vem de muito
tempo
menos 50 de cristo e sócrates um grande
pai da medicina na grécia antiga
dizia que a nossa inteligência estava na
cabeça e ele estava certo
platão por outro lado dizia que a nossa
alma imortal que abrigava a nossa
inteligência os nossos sentimentos
essa alma a alma imortal se encontrava
na cabeça mas a nossa alma mortal que
abrigava os nossos sentimentos se
encontrava no coração
aristóteles por outro lado discordava
dessa dicotomia da alma platônica e
dizia existir uma só alma se encontrava
também no coração
hoje com os avanços da neurofisiologia
temos que nos curvar a hipócrates pois
não só a inteligência uma base neuro
biológica dos nossos sentimentos e das
nossas emoções se encontra no cérebro
mas voltando à nossa questão inicial
pelo que o nosso coração bate um sentido
eo significado
eu acho sinceramente que existem pessoas
que passam os seus quase 3 bilhões de
batimentos sem saber e me arrisco a
dizer que não são poucas porque vivem no
piloto automático adendo contas
trabalhando para ganhar dinheiro
chegando na segunda feira esperando pela
sexta chegando no primeiro dia de
trabalho esperando pelas férias
recordando de manhã não vendo a hora do
dia passar logo para poder descansar e
dormir de novo
isso não me parece uma razão digna pela
qual seu coração deve bater mas parte
conversando outro dia a minha filha de
10 anos dirigindo na volta da escola
aliás é essa ela o nome dela beatriz
conversando outro dia com ela eu
perguntei com que ela tomava lanche no
intervalo da escola ea resposta que ela
me deu para uma pergunta tão simples e
surpreendeu
se a mãe que eu tomar um lanche com uma
amiga outro dia eu tomar um lanche com
outra mas na verdade eu procuro está com
quem mais precisa de mim naquele momento
eu não preciso dizer que eu quase chorei
nessa rota e que me encantou ver na
minha menininha o esboço dos sentimentos
que eu considero mais nobres no ser
humano a compaixão eo altruísmo
se você procurar no google significado
de compaixão você vai ver uma definição
quase perfeita com paixão substantivo
feminino eu gostei particularmente essa
parte é um sentimento piedoso de
simpatia para com a tragédia pessoal do
outro acompanhada de um desejo de
melhorá la
é uma participação espiritual na
infelicidade alheia que suscitam impulso
altruísta de ternura para com o sofredor
e realmente esse sentimento se imbricam
um empatia com paixão altruísmo empatia
capacidade de você sentir pelo outro
compaixão é capacidade de você sentir e
ter um curso de ajudar e altruísmo a
ação de efetivamente ajudá lo
esse é um consultório improvisado meu
uma tribo indígena no meio da floresta
amazônica
mas onde quer que o meu consultório
esteja firme o paciente espera de mim
nem isso compaixão eu entenda o seu
sofrimento me coloque no seu lugar me
importe e tenha um impulso genuíno de
ajudá lo com as ferramentas que a
medicina me proporcionou ser uma boa né
dica se use com habilidade o arsenal
científico da medicina isso é só uma
parte dos nossos corações não se tocarem
e se compadecer em estabelecendo uma
relação de empatia e estabelecendo uma
seria o intuito de aliviar o sofrimento
remédio nenhum do mundo irá funcionar
e essa não é uma suposição empírica
estudos científicos mostram por exemplo
que pacientes portadores de hiv
aderência ao tratamento a eficácia do
tratamento é muito maior que aqueles que
têm uma maior relação de empatia com os
seus médicos
é claro que isso não acontece só com os
pacientes portadores de hiv no decorrer
da vida
estabelecer relações de compaixão com as
pessoas que porventura cruzam nosso
caminho nos possibilita mais do que
meramente sentir a dor alheia
o ato de se compadecer na verdade
possibilita que o meu coração parta pelo
coração do outro
compartilhe a sua dor cruze as
fronteiras do meu peito e se permita
sentir a dor além e apesar desse e por
incrível que pareça essa é uma das mais
eficientes curas que eu conheço para as
nossas próprias dores comungar ator
um estudo científico realizado por
pesquisadores norte-americanos
acompanhou 900 pessoas no estado de
michigan e fez para essas pessoas duas
perguntas fundamentais
a primeira pergunta foi muito stress
você passou no último ano ea segunda
pergunta foi quanto tempo você passou
efetivamente ajudando pessoas próximas
colegas amigos familiares vizinhos
depois desse estudo acompanhou o
registro de óbito dessas pessoas pelos
próximos cinco anos e constatou um
evento surpreendente
as pessoas que passaram por eventos
estressantes no último ano
associados a sofrimentos intensos
relacionados a crises financeiras e
familiares
essas pessoas tiveram um aumento do seu
risco
o rei em 30%
por outro lado as pessoas que passaram
pelos mesmos eventos estressantes
mas por outro lado passaram uma parcela
significativa do seu tempo ajudando
outras pessoas
o aumento do risco de morrer dessas
pessoas é como se a compaixão o sentir
pelo outro eo altruísmo agir pelo outro
o culparam ajudar tivesse tido um efeito
protetor na vida dessas pessoas como se
cuidar e salvar se você é como se agir
como um anjo da guarda gay o fizesse com
que seu próprio corpo defende se agir
como um anjo da guarda de si próprio
um outro estudo científico realizado
pelas universidades da califórnia e da
carolina do norte acompanhou a expressão
genética de marcadores do processo
inflamatório e pessoas que se
consideravam felizes mas sabemos que o
processo inflamatório no nosso corpo
está relacionada com o desenvolvimento
de vários tipos de doenças como câncer
infarto agudo do miocárdio
sabemos também que o estresse e
sofrimento estão associados a níveis
mais elevados que esse processo
inflamatório
nesse estudo as pessoas que se
consideram felizes por ter uma vida
focada na satisfação dos seus próprios
desejos e prazeres de uma forma
hedonista essas pessoas apresentavam
altos níveis desses marcadores do
processo inflamatório
por outro lado as pessoas que se
consideravam felizes por ter uma vida
focada no outro
cheia de compaixão e altruísmo essas
pessoas apresentavam baixos níveis
desses mesmos marcadores do processo
inflamatório
isso é uma evidência científica afinam
tic
o seu coração bater pelo outro te traga
mais benefícios do que seria bater
exclusivamente por você
talvez hipócrates não estivesse é um
certo afinal vocês me perguntarem pelo
que o meu coração da arte
provavelmente eu responda aqui toda vez
que entra um paciente no meu consultório
e eu consigo me conectar com
praticamente com ele e consigo
satisfazer meu desejo de ajudar curando
ou aliviando o seu sofrimento de alguma
forma isso traz significado à vida que
estou vivendo
isso me dá prazer e só ele viu meu
sofrimento enquanto ser humano
isso me traz talvez seja a hora de nós
pensarmos em pelo que o nosso coração
bate porque esse coração de carne dentro
do peito um dia ia parar
não há a mínima negociação batimento de
número 3 milhões chegará e acho que aqui
ninguém tem muita ilusão de que isso não
vai acontecer
porém esse coração que pode ter um outro
significado que pode ater pelo outro se
eternizar fora de si
esse talvez bata para sempre dentro das
almas que encantar se compadecer pela
vida e talvez a beleza da vida esteja
exatamente em saber que o batimento de
número 3 milhões chegará que nós podemos
decidir como viver nada aqui
finalmente o de família pergunta pra
vocês pelo que o seu coração obrigada